18 heures les festivités se prépare dans
la salle de la mutualité à paris le lieu
choisi par benoît hamon pour la soirée
électorale de ce second tour
des soutiens évinois ont fait le
déplacement téléphone en main ils
obtiennent les premières tendances dans
les yvelines
pour l'instant j'ai pas de résultats
mais à mon avis ce sera triomphal pour
benoît hamon dans une demi heure c'est
vrai que le regain de participation est
aussi très très vivifiant pour le
résultat qui en sortira
ce soir mais c'est vrai qu'on reste
malgré tout serein et dans la tente
parce que tant que les résultats ne sont
pas proclamer on peut évidemment rien
rien annoncé à dire écoutez je suis
plutôt confiant j'ai un peu fait le tour
ce matin dans les yvelines
le taux de participation dans les
bureaux de vote à gauche ont beaucoup
participé dans un certains quartiers
notamment aux mureaux le taux de
participation a doublé donc c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle mais on attend les
résultats
l'impatience est à son comble tous les
sympathisants leur regard rivé sur leur
portable ou sur le grand écran à 20h45
les résultats tombent
[Applaudissements]
quand il se présente devant ses
sympathisants le député des yvelines se
pose en candidat pour l'élection
présidentielle
dès lundi je proposerai donc à tous les
candidats à cette primaire mais aussi à
tous ceux qui se reconnaissent dans la
gauche et l'écologie politique en
particulier yannick jadot et jean luc
mélenchon de nous penser qu'à l'intérêt
des français aux amis 4 un rassemblement
qui pourrait permettre à la gauche de se
qualifier au second tour une stratégie
politique partagée par l'ensemble des
militants
je pense que ce soir le bleu dur est
fait le plus important reste à faire est
le plus important c'est dès demain
la discussion à gauche pour permettre le
rassemblement et gagner cette
présidentielle
nous en avions déjà les prémices lors du
premier tour et le second tour a fait
que confirmer que les gens les électeurs
et les citoyens de gauche avaient un
besoin de renouvellement
il avait un besoin de rassemblement de
la gauche 58% nationalement 89% rattrape
je suis hyper content maintenant tout
reste à faire parce que c'est qu'une
primaire maintenant en route pour la
présidentielle et vers la victoire le 7
mai prochain dans les premiers sondages
donner après la primaire benoît hamon
serait créditée de 15% au premier tour
ils devanceraient jean luc mélenchon
donné à 10%